[Music]
no no no he's not a cop
he can't be wearing any of this it's
just a windbreaker it's not like I gave
him a badge and a gun yes both of those
things it's not loaded
that's when a cop gonna say a cool cop
catchphrase New York's finest just got a
whole lot funner Peralta it's no
coincidence you owners ship you want a
free cruise without entering a contest
how do you think that happened I don't
know maybe it's because I bought speed 2
on DVD and the internet realized that
cruises were one of my interests great
film sandy being a sarong
but the tix Oh me I brought you here
because I'm in peril peril don't my
peril somebody's trying to kill me and I
need protection
so I'll set for my best friend I am NOT
your best friend I'm your worst enemy
get that through your head it's this
kind of bickering it makes us such an
adorable couple
whatever Judi you're under arrest you
can't arrest me boo we're in
international waters which is also why I
can smoke as much weed as I want welcome
to the high seas no no way that that's
true Amy tell me I can arrest him right
now Judy's right we have no jurisdiction
technically this boat flies under the
flag of Uzbekistan Oh whose bags oh but
do you know how many crimes we're
forgiving 6 it's not so bad hundred no
that's way more Grand Theft Auto Grand
Theft Auto Grand Theft Auto Dawg fraud I
saw the guy fake Pekinese towards the
cat you will not win me over with your
use of 12 wasn't trying to
you're clearly friends with this man and
you've lost your objectivity Peralta or
have you lost your objectivity
what are you doing my bad though we will
even no just making a point here sit
down since I'm going to jail I want to
enjoy my time left on the outside put me
up in 5-star hotel like the Royce
unlimited room service and minibar
privileges 3 star hotel like the
Brooklyn earth $60 a day meal allowance
no minibar four-star hotel like the
Oneida 204 no minibar or alcohol but I
get to go crazy on candy and this agreed
oh one last thing
Diaz has to be nice to me
Omaha - call me big sugar huge mistake
but she'll never agree to that no I mean
let's do this big sugar Oh what
alright fine if this is going down I
want to be on this case and my sole
focus is Doug Judy he never leaves my
sights love it
Pontiac bandit and Jake PB&J ride again
reunited and it feels so good it's a
doink you don't want this because we oh
no no okay so you guys are which
Europeans looking about Shelby I'll make
the introductions
wait we can't just be Europeans what
country are we from what languages do
you speak French Spanish some Portuguese
obviously Greek enough Flemish to get by
tight what about you brought um I can do
a pretty good Italian accent you think
you could milk me so you're just doing
De Niro for me - parents I don't know am
I it's a terrible dinner I don't know
this is De Niro I think it's pretty good
we'll just make you Mary okay I got to
say the suit is growing on me that's
good is it triple breasted somehow it's
more such thing what about the girl in
Total Recall
triple bitties triple bitties I thought
you'd be happy to see me being so weird
oh I don't know I didn't sleep well last
night so I'm probably tired from that oh
and also this is a hostage situation
Wow
oh it's like that yes it's like that
what the hell I thought you went
straight I did I'm a hired car broker
now I procure luxury vehicles for the
rich and famous and I do it legally last
we got dropped off a Bugatti to the kid
the lists from stranger things you meant
Aston was he cool do him and the rest of
the gang hang out in real life you know
what no we are not chatting right now
you have three hostages
you mean you Pam in the two bombs ain't
not hostages I prefer to call them
collateral friendships I gave them each
500 bucks on my own pocket thanks again
to hug you the man died actually I'd
rather still not be a hostage Pam hasn't
come around on me yet tell I'm a nice
person Jake I'm sorry officer are you
friends with this criminal no not really
absolutely best friend it's the Laird
relationship friends judy smosh smosh
[Music]
who still sound like an angel sure
thank God you would a Peralta I don't
even let your best friend die I'm still
gonna arrest you I just can't do that if
you're dead what have you got to tell
yourself
baby steps it's hard get him out of his
shell tell me about it every time we get
emotional he's like noice smart okay can
we focus up here
Lobster Thermidor Baked Alaska it's so
fancy don't even sound like food yeah
come on or so or do it or no thanks I'm
on duty
come on Peralta are you gonna let the
criminal have all the fun all right fine
I'll have one Lobster Thermidor extra
Thermidor on the side I have no idea
what I'm ordering me neither
we're like culinary Magellan's you know
how we take this to the next level
bras robes
[Music]
me I mean nobody saw him but there was a
prolific car thief at the scene of the
crime
some of me I'm a cop now no you're not
the one don't have a badge and a gun the
dim blue line just got thick as hell
come on shoot it's not loaded look if I
was gonna jack a bunch of cars I
wouldn't bring to New York's best
detectives with me to the scene of the
crime flattering this is nonsense you're
off the case whoa whoa sir come on we're
chasing a murderer a murderer that just
stole a ton of cars who knows more about
that world than Doug Judy Plus remember
he doesn't get immunity unless he helps
us bring his brother I know but do you
want to get back her tea or not fine
he's still on the case Angie got cops
with the worst parking captain all over
the right to have the pictures wherever
they go the talking dog flies in outer
space yes we won't take your deals if
they think you're lying not lying I
don't want to be a criminal I love my
life as an average citizen I voted for
the first time this year it breakfast
for school board oh I don't know he had
a funny name he deserves a shot that's
why I voted for Stacy ladle anyways I'm
sorry but they're not cutting a deal so
sit I gotta turn myself in and let
Holloway kill my mama actually there
might be another way to get this done
I'm taking good negotiator hostage if
you come in here I will shoot him that
was so much fun
oh man you sounded really scary no no no
it was are you trembling your voice sold
it whatever he wants I just made that up
I was so in the moment dude seriously
you are a great hostage thanks Judy
you're a great hostage taker one where
is Judy I've looked everywhere he has to
be somewhere on this boat
no he doesn't sorry man Sun opening in a
hat take I can't go to jail
so cool you'll never get away from me
dude II can't hear what you're saying
you're real far away I'll just assume
you're finally admitting we're best
friends
no that is not what I'm saying thank you
means a lot to me enjoy the rest of your
crew just remember you got a five lady
don't be a Tang in the mud check your
pocket
boom boom boom boom but this isn't over
I will hunt you to the ends in here I
love you too I'm so proud of us for
being able to sing what are you still
standing there for go we'll be safe here
I know the owner he'd never turn me yeah
yeah I have the exact same relationship
with a guy who runs the laser tag place
I love I mean gun range
hirato who you are here stun for huh I
love laser tea we gotta go sometime man
so can you say that I wasn't stunting no
but it's done taking it's done it a
little bit I've got this coupon for a
private room yes right this way
we already have a song cued up feet
Judy what's up Peralta thank you so much
for coming
look I thought about it and I did you
dirty I never meant to cause you any
troubles yeah well you caused me a lot
talking to a pre-recorded video but it's
cool I know what you're saying I here
you go my heart what am I doing here I
feel the same way you're my best friend
too look I'm not coming back start a new
life here in San Diego stupid telling me
where you are come on man I know damn
San Diego everybody knows that place
sobs here's what I'm gonna say though
I'm sorry I won't be at your wedding
but I did record you a CD of original
smoosh jams that will consummate the
marriage it's on the table next to you
along with a little something else my
french kraler curse a pot now look
inside it the diamonds yes I cannot
believe you actually brought the
diamonds
yeah mistime that one no you're the best
look even though I am a scorpion
I will never drown your adorable little
frog ass so that's what I had to say I'm
sure I'll see you again at some point
now that coupon you got there it's for a
full hour in the private room
[Music]
you